this is a production of cornell
university
awesome thank you so much chelsea that
is you know
at this point i've given quite a few
seminars but it's by far my favorite
introduction i've got i have like
goosebumps right now so that feels
really good
i'm gonna take the opportunity to invite
anybody who
um wants to you don't have to i want you
to feel no pressure but to turn on your
video just so i can have something to
engage with i have a whole
whole screen of names right now many of
which are familiar but many who aren't
so if you're in a place where or you
want me to see
your reactions to the research i present
absolutely turn your videos on
and so today i'm going to tell you guys
as chelsea alluded to
all about the research i've done on
neotropical plant evolution
before i dive into the andes i'm going
to paint a picture of
the neotropics writ large and so the
neotropics are the region of the world
between the
tropics of cancer and capricorn in the
western hemisphere
stretching from northern or southern
mexico in the north in chiapas down
through northern argentina and the south
wrapping around to include the the
caribbean islands
and for biodiversity they're an
incredibly important part of the world
uh there are between 90 and 110 000
species of vascular plants
that are native to the neotropics and to
put this into a broader
um global context this means that
the neotropics may hold more plant
species than the entirety
of the african and asian tropics
combined
so really quite stunning levels of
neotropical diversity
and because i'm in a plant biology
department i know you guys know
a bunch of plants from this region but
here are some
um some of the plants that are probably
more familiar to
to you but also maybe to the people who
aren't plant biologists in your life
a bunch of um charismatic tropical
fruits like papayas and pineapples but
also kitchen staples
like um potatoes and chilies and the
neotropics is
as many of the sort of uncontroversial
and controversially wonderful plants it
has
also has some more controversial ones as
well including the coca leaf
which is um so important for the medical
industry but is also quite infamous for
for the drug trade um but as a botanist
when i think of the neotropics
this is more like the plant diversity
that i think of
the neotropics are home to almost all
species of cacti
bromeliads and of course the heliconias
that i wet my teeth on as an underground
in chelsea's lab
um implants that might be less familiar
as well
including things like this big leaf
gunnera this
formerly topabaya now blackia species
being
pollinated by an orchidv and many many
species
of the primarily tropical order now
piggy hayley's including this
anthodiscus species here
and a major question that drives my
research but also plenty of other folks
research including i think
people in your department who are coming
at it from a totally different angle
than me
is what explains this neotropical
hyperdiversity
there are of course abiotic explanations
that include simply time and area that
the neotropics are both big and old
but also climate and aspects of the
landscape themselves including hydrology
and and mountain uplift and prominently
today my top will feature
andean uplift but there are plenty of
biotic factors as well that may underlie
diversification plant diversification in
this region
including things a little bit inherent
to the species like potential to
hybridize or deform polyploids
um also adaptations to soil
environments and other parts of the
abiotic niche and of course
biotic interactions whether they're
mutualisms with pollinators or seed
dispersers
or um antagonisms like the relationship
between
um plants and their herbivores and
if you know my research you know i'm
sort of stuck on one of these potential
or one of these uh biotic mutualisms
hummingbird pollination and i think this
is a really good example
of how the neotropics have just such
fantastic biolo
biological interactions ongoing
throughout
their entire landscape and so many
plants have converged
to take advantage of this particular
pollinator
and to get at um what drives me a
tropical plant evolution
my research program takes a clade
focused approach
um but is very integrative across
subclades of biology of especially
evolution and i integrate
macroevolutionary studies with
microevolution
with species ecology in my research
program sort of that
that happy zone right there in the
middle but importantly my research
is always conducted in a systematic
context so
understanding phylogenetic relationships
as well as having a solid understanding
of alpha taxonomy
underlies all the research that i do and
this of course means that herbarium
specimens are central to the work that i
do
um a lot of the data i will present to
you today came either
in part or in whole from our varying
specimens and so
they're just such an important source of
data for the evolutionary biologists
in addition to be an important um a
place for a taxonomist to really
get to understand a group in its
complexity
and so my my research program now that i
have my own lab at lsu takes a
two-pronged approach
my first prong is to go really deep into
a single model clay to try to understand
the evolutionary processes that give
rise to um
andy and biodiversity and here i use the
neotropical bell flowers
this will be the most of my talk today
but there's also a second prong
that in which i am trying to understand
taxonomy uh phylogeny and evolution of
groups that are totally understudied
the neotropics for being as species-rich
and um
rich in their interactions as they are
are surprisingly understudied
um from a phylogenetic perspective
so i'm going to hop in and tell you a
little bit about that first prong right
now
um the neotropical bell flowers are what
i consider emerging model clay to
understand indian plant evolution
they comprise about 600 species total
across
three different subgroups the core
genera that i'll spend most my time
talking about today
are center pogon burmystera and
cyphocampolis
collectively these genera are sister to
a group of high elevation endemic taxon
and the genus lysophonia
um and together those two are sister to
four species of lagelia down in chile
the the the tupas um it's a truly
neotropical group
going from mexico down through argentina
um but their species richness is by far
highest in the cloud forest of the andes
and this group across its about 600
species not surprisingly
is very diverse in its ecology and
morphology
and i think the floral diversity in this
clade really exemplifies that
here are some of the species that i've
been lucky enough to collect throughout
fieldwork aminotropics
um this is lysophomia that uh that high
elevation endemic i mentioned has a
teeny flower that's
probably bee pollinated but the rest of
the flowers on this slide are vertebrate
pollinated
whether they're pollinated by
hummingbirds in these bright colors here
or by bats in these more dull colors and
this
impressive floral diversity is paratune
equally impressive
though um maybe less colorful diversity
and overall growth form
and here again i'm going to mention
really fast this is lysophomia
shown here out in the wild and there's
some moss behind it for scale so it's a
really tiny little plant
um but it occurs in the same overall sub
uh clade
as hifocampus tunarensis it's not a huge
tree but it's still a tree with a pretty
substantial single bowl um
and growth form within this clade sort
of spans that entire gamut
whether we're talking about xerophytes
that are growing in the guiana shield
uh hemi epiphytes growing or hemiapple
fights in the genus for myscara
or um this sort of dr
seuss-like monocollis shrub thing that's
holding on to its
um sinest leaves so really
just a fantastic group to to get to
study evolution in
and as i alluded to systematics is at
the heart
of of my research so understanding how
these 600
species should be delimited and how
their species are related is really
important
so of course part of my research does
involve going into the field and into
the herbarium and describing
new species um but it also involves
establishing a phylogenomic or
phylogenetic and more recently
phylogenomic framework
to understand relationships that can be
used to then understand
macroevolutionary patterns so i'm going
to tell you a little bit about the
the work that i've done and establishing
the phylogeny of this group
sorry about that you probably saw my
twitter a little um
thanksfeyway um anyway so
the i'm gonna tell you about where what
i've done research i've done in
phylogenetics but also
um the the work that's ongoing
and this is i think a strand of my
research that will always have something
active going on
you know i will always be trying to
understand more and more about this
group of
species as i mentioned at the beginning
as a whole they can be
subdivided into three major clades and
it turns out
that geolo geography is really informing
relationships in this clade and
for example we found that caribbean
species of psycho campolos are actually
really distantly related from
other members of its closely allied
genera um in the mainland
and so this green clade i've highlighted
here is
what we've come to refer to as a central
paragon of clade and this is
the group of about 500 species that's
really
diverse in their um ecology and
morphology
here i'm showing you the phylogeny at at
the left
and you can immediately notice that
there's only only one monophyletic genus
here
um burmystera um is
in green is monophyletic and this
monophyle is well supported
by um molecular phylogenetic analysis
but further
it's supported by um morphological
synaptomorphies as well
this includes a dilated anthra orifice
so unlike other lobelity it doesn't
close its anther tube
um that's an adaptation probably to bat
pollination
and as is this inflated corolla opening
that it has it also has iso diametric
seeds
you know well-established clay the other
two genera
however are polyphyletic and sort of
wildly so with respect to one another
with central pogon forming eight
separate subclades and cyphocampolis 11.
now this is a reflection of this
artificial taxonomy that's based on
fruit type
like burmeisters and true pogon produce
these
animal dispersed berries and cyphocampus
on the
other hand hand produces these capsules
that are abiotically dispersed
maybe wind occasionally takes them up
and and takes them far but mainly
they're probably just gravity dispersed
um aside from these two traits these
genera overlap and pretty much
all characters whether vegetative or
or reproductive so this striking
non-modified
um is not necessarily surprising
but it does underlie really interesting
macroevolutionary
trend which is that fruit evolution has
been incredibly dynamic within this
clade
from an ancestral um capsular state we
see the
independent evolution of of
berries about eight times independently
and each of these eight evolutions is
associated with the origin
um of a well-supported morphologically
well-defined clade
and just to show you sort of the end
product
of the um convergent evolution of
berries
um i've put up examples of five of those
sub planes here
these are all um either in burma sarah
here or central pogon
and i think these are useful in showing
the fact that yes these are all berries
they're all fleshy fruits with many many
seeds
um but that convergent evolution and
function is not necessarily a reflected
and convergent evolutionary form and
there's actually quite a lot of
variation in the in the form of or the
fruit morphology in this group
so we're continuing to build a
phylogenetic framework for this group
both at the broad level
and an undergraduate lauren frankel's
been really helpful there
and at more targeted lineages and my
graduate student janet mansery's been
working on establishing
the phylogeny of a subplate of central
pogon here
and my our current work uses targeted
sequence capture
um which is a method that is really
robust to low quality dna which is
important because
we use a lot of herbarium specimens as a
major source of dna
um because with 600 species even though
even back when field work was possible
it's really hard to get full sampling
across the neotropics via field work
and so this method has been really great
for us
even though herbarium specimens aren't
always
a panacea to getting really great data
they are
i'm useful so herbarium samples perform
poorly compared to silica dried samples
even in targeted sequence capture
we see that the total number of
assembled base pairs in our data set
is less in herbarium specimens as
compared to
um silica dried leaf tissue that we
sequenced from
the average conflict length is lower the
number of really long context similarly
is lower
but yet they've done a really good job
at allowing this method isn't a really
good job of allowing us
to put new species into the tree that i
failed at previously
and this includes these three species
here
um cyphocampulus planchonus
is a species that's endemic to venezuela
so even if i could go to the field right
now i wouldn't be able to collect silica
tissue for this species because of the
socio-political situation in venezuela
but
thanks to missouri botanical garden i
was able to incorporate
incorporate it into a phylogeny here
similarly we were able
to include a central pokemon
electrolophus a new species that i'm
describing with bruce stein
into into the phylogeny and as well as
my my white whale
on a psycho campus novelist i've been
trying to include in a phylogeny since i
was a graduate student because i just
love its linear leaves but wasn't able
to when i was using sanger sequencing
but we now have it
pretty well resolved i should say really
quickly that our phylogenomic analyses
really broadly agree with um
that the first phylogeny i showed you so
while we're continuing to add
information
the the overall story of evolution in in
the central background enclave is is
really consistent
so we've used this phylogeny to really
understand macroevolution in this clade
and i'll tell you a little bit about
how we've looked at the abiotic and
biotic drivers of diversification in
this clade especially in the context of
the andes
so i want to introduce you even further
to the tropical andes
which the andes themselves are a
continental
scale mountain range searching from
venezuela
down through patagonia but the tropical
andes sort of end at the
in northern argentina there are
global biodiversity hot spot that um
spans about or that encompasses about
1.5
kilometers million square kilometers um
which is less than one percent of the
world's terrestrial surface
however the tropical andes are home to
15
of all angiosperm diversity fully 40
000 species of angiosperms are native to
this region
and this high level of species richness
is paired with
high endemism so it's a really special
area
and the uplift of the andes geologically
is
pretty recent at least in the the
tropical um parts of the andes which
in northern colombia you can argue are
still uplifting and they definitely have
been very active in the last million
years
so this this process of really active
recent uplift has been invoked time and
time again
to explain elevated diversification
rates in
really distantly related clades
including um
hummingbirds glasswing butterflies and
these glass frogs
and in the plants world i think time
after time again this has been
established but perhaps
most famously we can think of the andean
lupines
which hopped down from mexico about one
and a half million years ago into south
america and diversified into more than
80 species pretty quickly
but i think it's important to consider
that the andes the tropical andes
are not one monolithic habitat type that
are instead have a whole lot of habitat
heterogeneity within them
and here are four of the distinct
habitat types that
characterize this region at the highest
part of the andes
there are high elevation grasslands
characterizes characterized by lots of
grasses and
sedges that form um that form tussocks
like this
and you know in the paramount in
colombia and
venezuela you have also these espaletti
this really charismatic plant genus
as you go on down the wet eastern slope
of the andes
um these grasslands including paramount
give way to cloud forests which are
where i've done most of my field work
and they're the world's most
species-rich habitat type
super verdant lush wet and cloud filled
throughout the year
and they're characterized by short trees
and shrubs that are absolutely full of
epiphytes
including orchids mosses ferns
bromeliads like you see here
and as you keep on going down the in an
elevation that cloud forest gives way to
lowland
rainforest including the amazon basin
there on the western side
which um well maybe not a species which
is very um lush and vibrant and
absolutely um charismatic in its flora
and fauna
but not all andean landscapes are
green and lush there are lots of dry
habitats as well and in fact some of the
most
arid habitats are um in proximity to the
andes and this includes a lot of
seasonally dry forests and really arid
inter andean valleys and it can be so
dry that cacti can be a predominant
growth form so um as to be expected i
would argue diversification
is not um homogeneous across these
different habitats
and so we see that diversification has
been
really fast and really recent we have
clades that have
um originated in the last million years
and less
in the paramose which makes sense
because they're the top of the andes
they're the most
the youngest habitat type in this in
this region um
and so this is the world's most fastest
biodiversity hot spot
but we also know that the drier areas of
the andes are a little bit more
relictual
and the clades that they have are that
they house
tend to be old and relatively slow
evolving
a relatively few cloud forest clades
have been studied in the context of
diversification i think in part because
there are lots of unwieldy clades that
are native here lots of just
very high species richness hard to hard
to infer
phylogenys here that make the subsequent
inference of diversification rates
difficult
but here we use the neotropical bell
flowers as a model
to look at neotropical or andean
diversification
and first we establish a time calibrated
phylogeny
we showed that from the origin of the
clade about 15 million years ago
until about 5 million years ago
diversification rates remained
relatively flat and relatively slow but
at 5 million years ago
diversification rates exploded and we
see that net diversification
rates um ticked up super quickly
coinciding with the origin of the
central cargonic plate this group of 550
species
and in fact this is a really special um
clade in terms of diversification rate
we see that the the rates that we have
estimated for central pogon are
higher than other um andean lineages
with fast diversification rates
including hummingbirds and those
espaledia that i showed a few slides ago
and similarly they're also higher than
um many
famous rapid radiations in the hawaiian
islands another area characterized by
sort of
young geology and rapid diversification
rates
and in lineages those lineages include
hawaiian drosophila
and the hawaiian silver swords but what
explains
this this really elevated
diversification rate
well applying um state dependent
diversification models we found evidence
that an
association with vertebrate pollinators
um
results in a six-fold increase in net
diversification
rate rates as compared to invertebrate
pollination and similarly
that relationships with fruit dispersers
probably small
small bats and birds is associated with
the higher rate
at diversification than those capsular
fruits that just sort of drop their
seeds
and this suggests that mutualism
specifically with verdigris
are really important to the
diversification of this clique
but we also found evidence for
um for the abiotic environment
also driving diversification and here we
see
here we we're really excited about this
model because it's one of the first
times geological data has been
incorporated
into a model of diversification um
and so we thought this was really
exciting and novel
on this side you see a model of anion
pascal
ambient elevation through time and at
the right
you see the results of our analysis
which is basically an extension of a
birth death model but instead of
modeling through time we model against a
time dependent variable
so the elevation here in our best
fitting model we find that extinction is
not a significant parameter we have a
pure birth model
we see that speciation instead it seems
to be very tightly linked to past
elevation of the andes
a really exciting result and though not
surprising because again this has been
about time and time again across
other enclaves as well this result was
corroborated by
two other busy analyses one showing that
andy and taxa have higher rates in that
diversification
than taxes that occur outside of the
andes and similarly those at higher
elevations
um have higher rates in a
diversification than those at lower
elevations
and so across these series of
diversification analyses we're able to
show that it's a complex interplay
of both abiotic factors um climate
and which i didn't show but climate hand
andy and uplift but also biotic factors
those relationships with mutualists
that underlies rapid diversification and
neotropical bell flowers
and i would argue that's probably going
to be true in most lineages that occur
across this really heterogeneous
topographically complex area um clades
are able to have so many species because
of the scale
of this mountain range and because of
the the many different um
uh sort of ecological interactions that
can happen within this
this matrix uh attacks are able to
locally adapt and you have what results
are these morphologically
diverse species-rich clades that
characterize the tropical andes and
we're beginning to see a similar pattern
across
other taxa as well in which
diversification often a very
um morphologically rich uh clades begins
in the late maya scene and this
coincides at the time
at which those mountains were tall
enough to begin to capture
moisture coming in from the amazon basin
forming the clouds that gives cloud
forests their names
and so we see this in bromeliads
blueberries passion flowers
viburnums and even lycopods
and as i mentioned before i really do
think that the evolutionary
ability of different lineages to for
example
converge on unhummingbird pollination or
to shift fruit type to
fit a different disperser has allowed
the coexistence of so many species
and this allowed us to
with this framework i was able to sort
of meld
macroevolution of species ecology to
understand at a macroevolutionary scale
how evolution of pollination syndromes
has proceeded in neotropical bell
flowers
for those of you are unfamiliar with
pollination syndromes there are suites
of floral characteristics that are
associated with the attraction of a
particular floral visitor
in this clade hummingbird pollination
and bat pollination are relevant
they actually share quite a few
characteristics and bell flowers
flowers going to be tubular tubular and
produce a lot of nectar because both
hummingbirds and bats
are warm breaded pollinators that need a
lot of energy to survive
the hummingbird pollinated flowers tend
to be brightly colored
to match sort of the high visual acuity
of hummingbirds
they're flowering during the day or they
have diurnal emphasis
they don't have a floral odor and that's
because hummingbirds don't smell very
well
and most importantly so for pollination
efficacy they have really narrow floral
openings
and hummingbirds are best at visiting
the most narrow possible
aperture within the constraints of their
um
bill size so functionally this is a very
important trait
fat pollinated flowers on the other hand
tend to be pale at color they might
stand out a little bit
um at night which of course when bats
are active and
why we see a night flowering flowers or
nocturnal emphasis
in bat pollinated groups they also tend
to have unpleasant floral odors
or at least tend to be very sulfurious
so um
kind of kind of skunky and they have
importantly a wide floral opening
and i like to think these bat pollinated
flowers are sort of bat head shape
because the bats just put their whole
head in when they visit
and so i'm going to really quickly show
you guys a video about pollination
because i think it tends to be the least
familiar pollination syndrome that i
talk about
so here's central pogon niagara cans
it's flowering in the cloud forest of
ecuador
you can see it's a really wide flower or
corolla opening there
and these are its big old stamens just
waiting to put pollen on
the anurai fish gelato bat that's about
to visit it
you see as the bat puts its head in it
reaches its tongue
all the way to the base of this 10
centimeter long flower
and as it's doing that uh pollen's being
placed very specifically
at the nape of this fat snack so just a
really fantastic interaction
maybe even more impressive when you
realize that this fat has the longest
tongue
per body size of any vertebrate which it
has evolved to um
two it's a practical evolution with
center pogo night or cans it's
the only bat that's able to get to the
bottom of this
um very long flower and subsequently
centripetal cancer relies on this bat
for
for reproduction and so we're really
interested
in how pollination syndromes evolved
across the clay not just within a
species and so we collected a bunch of
data
relevant to pollination biology from
herbarium specimens
and the first thing i did with that data
was to pop it into a phylogenetically
informed principle components analysis
this is a a beast of the slides i'll go
ahead and walk you through it
but the overall take home is that
pollination syndromes were really well
supported in this claim
here we see bat pollinated uh flowers
uh morphosphere bat pollinated no we
have flowers
um that are bat pollinated and green
hummingbird pollinated flowers and
either pink
or white and species for which we know
from really good pollination ecology
we know their pollinators have blue
around the outside
um so the first pc axis is mainly
capturing size variation and it doesn't
do a great job of splitting hummingbird
versus bat flowers
which is not surprising because they're
actually pretty similar in size these
how many birds and bats
however the second pc axis does a really
good job of splitting
um bat from hummingbird pollinated
flowers and this axis
not surprisingly is capturing more shape
variation
we go from flowers that are wide and
relatively short and have
big anthers um on this part of the axis
to flowers that are longer narrower and
have small anthers up here
a third pc axis further separates
species that are obligately pollinated
by this
wonderful hummingbird species here
eutoxaries the sickle bell hummingbird
and this axis is capturing variation in
curvature
when we put these results onto that
phylogeny we see
just like fruit evolution pollination
syndrome evolution has been really
dynamic in this clade
we see that ancestral pollen that
ancestrally
this clade was hummingbird pollinated
and here i'm showing you the product
or the i'm showing you six species that
are plesiomorphically hummingbird
pollinated
meaning from the base of that tree all
the way to the present their lineage is
inferred to have been hummingbird
pollinated
and so i just want you to notice that
the flowers well there is quite a bit of
variation within them they are sort of
overall similar in their in their bowel
plan
within hummingbird pollination we have
this origination of an obligate
pollination by a sickle bill
hummingbirds this lovely guy
a single time but it's um
not an evolutionary dead end this
obligate specialization and instead we
see multiple occasions in which an evil
relationship with this bird has been
lost
and fantastically we see that that
pollination has evolved about 14
14 times independently within this clade
and here i'm showing you seven so if we
um examples from fully half of those
independent evolutions of that
pollination
and compared to those hummingbird
pollinated flowers you can see the
convergent
um origination of those flowers here and
they tend to be um overall similar and
those traits that we measure that are
functionally really important
but there's a lot of personality to
these flowers as well across the
different
um uh originations and so not
surprisingly
there's a suite of adaptive traits uh we
we see
evidence for evolution and pollination
syndromes
via the application of these ornstein
ulumbak models that allow us to look at
um correlated evolution within
pollination syndromes
so what this means as lineages shift
from hummingbird to bat pollination
their traits change simultaneously as
well
so for example as we go from flowers
that are long
long and have short peduncles this is
important in hummingbird pollination
we um as we shift to bat pollination
flowers simultaneously get wider
and get those long put uncles that are
so characteristic of that pollinated
flowers
and but despite this really dynamic
pattern of
pollination syndrome evolution and this
evidence for the macroevolutionary
importance
of um of these pollinators and driving
morphological evolution
we don't see any differences in
diversification rate
between hummingbird and bat pollinated
lineages um
and so i would argue that instead like i
said a few slides ago so this clay's
ability to shift so readily
between the pollination syndromes that
has allowed this clay to
host so many species and this
observation really motivated uh my next
research question which is what role do
pollinatorships play in speciation
within this clade and this bit allows me
to to put together the microevolution
and species ecology
parts of that venn diagram and
to so to get at this we we studied a
system in bolivia
of three different um central pokemon
species
central pogon britonianes centro pogo
mendonas and central pogan and canis
shown here a little worse for the wear
after a day of riding in the car with us
um so they're all all these species are
endemic to bolivia but they have really
different ranges within bolivia
central pogon brittonians and mendonas
they're both high elevation species
they're occurring at
the highest extent of cloud forest right
before it transitions to grasslands
but brittonianis it's a very narrow
endemic
it's just found in you know a handful of
populations outside of la paz
central program mendonas on the other
hand is this widespread taxon
that's found throughout this elevational
band throughout bolivia
center pokemon and canis is sort of like
brittonians it has a relatively
um narrow distribution though not nearly
as narrow as brittonianis
but importantly it's occurring lower on
the mountain slopes
than brutonians and mandona so this is
sort of a low cloud forest species
and this was a really interesting study
system for us
because of where one of the species fell
within the
morphological space and we see that
center program mandonis which we
inferred to be hummingbird pollination
pollinated based on its red flower color
however it was falling sort of on the
outskirts of fat morpho space
and so that led us to ask is this what's
what's the better signal
color or shape or is there something
more complex going on
so we set up a bunch of cameras and and
um
to see what was happening with the
pollination of these three species
and center pogon and canis with its big
white flowers we predicted would be bat
pollinated
and we do see in fact that bats were
really good and
regular visitors to this species down at
those lower warmer elevations
we saw we saw um
hummingbirds visiting these flowers as
well i want you to notice however that
when this bird is going into the flower
it's not always making contact with
those reproductive organs
and in a second here it's going to zoom
down to this flower down in the bottom
left
and i want you to pay attention it's
going to enter that flower from the side
totally issuing any sort of contact with
the reproductive organs and so
this hummingbird well it is a floral
visitor is often acting as a nectar
robber in the system
it's costly to this plant so not
not as good a visitor as that last bat
who even though it was a real quick
visit
did a really good job of transferring
pollen
so of course we were most interested in
what was going on in central pogan
mandonis
and we saw that hummingbirds do in fact
visit this flower so
you know that's sort of what we
predicted based on the flower color but
with that morpho space we also thought
bats might be good visitors and
to my delight they were
um and and so across
uh 243 hours of video we see
that there's a gradient of pollination
specialization in this clad from
primarily bat pollination
in central pogon in canis to a pretty
balanced
generalist in central pokemon mendonas
which relies on both hummingbirds
and bats for effective pollination with
central pogon britonianis sort of
in that middle zone its primary
pollinator is certainly bats
though hummingbirds are important
secondary pollinators
and this was of course a really fun
result for us because what this meant is
that
um mandonis as us balanced generalists
that color and shape mismatch
were sort of underlying its
ecological generalism so this really
sort of interesting result where we're
able to use macroevolutionary analyses
to actually predict something about
species ecology normally it's sort of
done the opposite way of course
being an evolutionary biology a
biologist i put this in a phylogenetic
context
and it's actually it gets even more
interesting
these are each other's closest related
species and this is strong support in
the entire phylogeny
as a whole if we zoom on into just the
subclade
we see that central programmer tonyanis
and central program mendonas
are sister species that occur in
sympathy
that are sharing pollinators which is a
really sort of stunning result
and their sister to central pelagon and
canis was whom they share one of their
key pollinators
and maybe individual pollinators too
bats can certainly go up and down in
elevation
in a way an individual plant can't um
and and this and canis is of course
occurring in parapatria to them
and so this is a really stunning result
with very close relatives sharing
pollinators
in close geographic proximity
it's further this pattern is further
supported by phylogeographic results
and we find whether we're applying sort
of this astral species tree framework we
see
we have really strong support for
monofilament of each of these species
and we do a pca of the snip data as well
we see that
they're really sort of in different
parts of
of that pca space so real strong support
for monophylee
but when we analyze the snip data in a
population context look for potential
intragression
we don't see a whole lot of evidence of
introgression within this system
sure there might be some cases of
individuals that are
um maybe the product of hybridization
or introgression but it doesn't seem
like hybridization is swamping out
everything
in the system like you might predict if
um these were closely relative
related species sort of swamp um that
didn't have reproductive isolation
involved and so of course
we want to know whether or not at this
point if this is if these individuals
reflect recent introduction or maybe
this is sort of
ancestral sorting um and we're still
analyzing this data
but a really interesting result that we
have that's sort of hard to reconcile
with that last slide
is that using a method that looks at
phylogenetic invariants to find
hybridization or evidence of
hybridization we find really strong
support for
hybrid origin essentia program and
donuts just sort of
um counter-intuitive too because it's
the species that's sort of
the most different i was actually
expecting that this species might be
a hybrid but if this is the case
a pattern that would be consistent with
our structure results
on the last slide here and this is a
pattern in which um central pokemon
mandonis arose via aloe polyploidy
between two species
and then through time was able to evolve
sort of these private snips
um and of course if aloe polyploidy is
invoked
is actually what's at play reproductive
isolation would have happened at the
time
of origination and so this is a
potential um
that we are currently investigating into
what may be allowing these three species
to co-exist
but as we continue to analyze this data
we still have strong evidence that
whether or not reproductive they're
completely reproductively isolated or if
it's
um or if they are still
able to have gene flow we do know that
pollen transfer is being minimized by
morphological traits
here we see that center pogon
brittonianis and mendonus have
significantly different stamen lengths
and this is
of course important because it
determines placement of pollen on those
fat and hummingbird bodies
but this difference is very much
exaggerated in sympatry
we have about ten percent shorter
statements than central poverty of
central program mendonas when it
co-occurs with brittonianis
and so in this system it seems like
there's differential pollinator use
that's mediated by key differences in
floral shape
um and and likely in competitive
uh reproductive incompatibility that's
due to potential hybrid origin of one of
the
players here that allows these three
species to
co-occur in close geographic proximity
in this really complex region
providing some insight into what at a
clade level
may be driving this pattern of rapid
diversification
and sort of high species richness in the
andes
we're continuing to look at this
intersection of microevolution and
species ecology
in the context of pollinator evolution
in in this clade and here we're really
interested especially
in that origin of the obligate
interaction with the sickle-built
hummingbird
and in this case we're not just
interested in the relationship between
central or central pogon and the
hummingbird but its entire
um suite of food plants which also
includes heliconia
which again i study as an undergrad of
chelsea and so
um two members of my lab janet and laura
are busy
working on the system janet's
establishing a phylogenetic
framework for this clay they use central
paragonic clay that's pollinated
for the most part but not exclusively
bicycle bills
and laura's been really diving into it a
system within costa rica
here we have central pogon granulosus
this curvy flowered species
sister to center pokemon celenofolius
these two species have really different
floral well different enough floral
morphology that it suggests
that sense of prolonged granulosus
relies on a single
um hummingbird within its pollinator
community whereas the lanifolius might
rely on up to six species of
hermit hummingbirds with curved bills
and
um and again we have this situation
where we have sister species
co-occurring with these really important
differences
in floral shape and so laura
wanted to understand what might be
allowing these two species to co-occur
so she took measurements across
uh from herbarium specimens that have
been collected in monte verde costa rica
uh where these two species occur they
overlap at mid elevations but
centripetal and celenofolius these
circular dots goes higher up on the
mountains than centropogon granulosus
the squares which go lower down the
mountains and laura did see a little bit
of overlap in the
floral amorphous space between the two
um
you see sort of especially around here
you see a little bit of overlap between
those circles and those squares however
where species do co-occur in the
mountain
we don't see any overlap we see this gap
in morphology
and so this is again a pattern
consistent with
um character displacement following a
recent speciation
and had everything on the way that we
had expected
um and i wasn't giving a talk on zoom
today we would have been in
in costa rica over the summer collecting
pollinator data and population genetic
data for the system to really test that
hypothesis
but hopefully soon and we really think
this is a great
system to integrate macro and micro
evolution with ecology
and again because we know the
systematics we're able to ask some
really focused questions
and so most of my talk so far is really
focused on that first prong that really
deep um dive into a single clade and i'm
just gonna end my talk
by um telling you a little bit of the
research you're doing on more of that
broadside and
the taxonomy and evolution of nature
understudy neotropical plant lineages
including these guys here so my lab is
busy establishing the first phylogenys
for these
clades here fresiera and the pentaphilic
casey
in the eric haleys a lot of people don't
know that family
marissa casey or otoba in the nutmeg
family marissa casey
uh helia and pele correa in the um
coffee family rubiaceae in this high
elevation endemic genus of millistones
and brachiodam
and these groups are really good
compliments to neotropical bell flowers
because they have
different natural history different
environmental preferences different
ecological interactions and so we'll be
able to
compare how they're responding to
the different aspects of the neotropical
landscape to really begin to understand
a more integrated um perspective
on on the a tropical plant evolution and
i'm just going to quickly show you a few
of
the examples of the impact of the andes
on diversification in this group
so for example in brachiodam that diego
is working on
he sees that species ranges to be really
really
narrow um even those fema species tend
to be
really really different in close
proximity and what this suggests to us
these species ranges
is that once diego finally gets that um
that phylogeny he's currently working on
that we're gonna see
that's um the andes have been a real
motor for speciation that alopatry
um in durian mountain uplift and
plasticine glaciations has probably
driven evolution in this clade
however in other lineages such as otoba
which is more of a low cloud forest
clade
we see that the andes instead are really
important biogeographic
barrier since the evolution of this the
origin of this clay that hopped over
from africa about 5 million years ago
um it's only been able to cross the
andes a single time
which makes some sense these are really
big big fruits that are
pollinated by big body birds and
primates so those don't cross mountains
very often
but the single time otoba has been able
to hop over the andes
it became very well established and has
become one of the 10 most ecologically
dominant
sp um genera in the western amazon
and of course and helia that my grad
student lemon lemon's working on
she has really good evidence that the
different ecological interactions that
these species can have
are really different depending on what
the environment
within the neotropics you're in and sort
of unlike in central pogon where we see
hummingbird and bat pollinated species
going crazy
in cloud forests instead she sees that
um hawk moths gonna be really important
pollinators
in cloud forests which really gets to
the fact that while we are searching for
generalities
in in andy and plant evolution
throughout our research
there are also going to be a lot of
wonderful idiosyncrasies that we find
and
it's really by comparing differences
between clades that will be able to tell
a fully integrated um story of andy and
plant evolution
but i hope i've convinced you that the
andes sort of their continental scale
and that opportunity for local
adaptation
and tons of aloe patriot is really one
of the key reasons
why the neotropics are so diverse
and while i love to do fieldwork in this
amazingly beautiful part of the world i
actually end up spending more of my time
in herbaria and today i told you about
taxonomic data morphological data
distribution data and dna sequence data
that i got
all from herbarium specimens herbarium
specimens are so important
in becoming literate in a group to be
able to
ask to pose these these big mac
revolutionary questions and they're
continuingly broad source of data um
of very different types as well and so
it's been really great being able to be
um to spend time in her barrier and so
with that i'm going to say
thank you including to those
institutions that
i visited to be able to collect the data
those are very listed below
i want to acknowledge my amazing lab
whose
um sort of diverse perspectives and just
the ways they approach science have
really pushed me as a scientist
and as a mentor and of course i also
have fantastic co-authors
and have had luck in the field and with
funding
and so with that i have no idea if i oh
i think i might have time for questions
i can take any questions if you don't
want to ask a question in this public
zoom format
feel free to shoot me a question um at
my email address up here or find me on
twitter
um and i'm happy to talk one-on-one as
well
so thank you i think i have to leave
this to see if there are any chat
questions
this is um the clap emojis make me happy
yeah so if anyone wants to ask any
questions feel free to unmute and ask a
question
um or uh you can place it into the chat
i i have a question uh hi hi laura can
you hear me
i can't uh this is gaura hi
hi um so we uh in our discussion we
spoke about
how self-compatibility has evolved in
insulin hybridities in this area
and actually there are two species that
have passed the
amount of zone again in solanum which
have
evolved from self-incompatibility to
compatibility
because they have been moving through
the andes and i was wondering what is
the general
frequency of of shifting from
not just the pollination modes but also
from self-con
incompatibility to compatibility in in
different systems
if you come across that information
that is such a good question and one of
those so
this morning when we were talking i was
like i wish i had that data for all
these species because the system you're
working on you do have so much data
unfortunately i don't have all that data
but i can tell you that in general
species of labelity tend to be
um self-compatible but they tend to not
be self-pollinated often because of the
morphology of their flower
and so um these are um
two-phase flowers first we have it in
male phase
and that's first this is actually really
early female phase
but um when i wonder if there's a better
slide for this
well we're gonna use this pretend that
and you don't see that sigma
popping out there and so there is a this
phase
where pollen's gonna be taken out of the
flower
first and um only after that
do we see the the stigma coming out and
opening and being receptive and usually
that stigma doesn't come out until
pollen has been um shed
completely and in fact it's part of part
of like the
a constraint of growth of that um
the stigma column is that it's pushing
against pollen and until pollen release
is is released it can't really grow out
and so that's sort of my frustrating
answer is i don't think shifts are going
to be super important
but it has definitely not been studied
in much detail i can tell you that there
are hybrids between species so it looks
like it can be fairly hard to evolve
or it's not always speciation
isn't always associated with
reproductive isolation in this group
and i think that my postdoc advisor
nathan muchal is looking at these sort
of
potential for hybridization across
species which might give some insight
into that
but we really don't know anything about
median system in
in this group thank you
yeah i wish we did that hi laura
this is joyce can you hear me i can how
are you doing hi
thank you for that great talk that was
really inspirational it's really nice to
see you
um i wrote down two questions one of
which you answered
while you were talking which is always
great and then the second question
um was about the the the three species
that you looked at
uh with the red yellow and white colors
and then
it's really interesting results there do
you ever the first question
pertaining to that is do you see
intermediate colors between those three
species um that's one question and i
asked that because
uh you said this kind of briefly that
when
two of those species are in sympatry um
the
the stigma length are are more
exaggerated
could do you also see other floral
traits related to their pollination
syndrome that are also exaggerated such
as the color
or is that data not really possible
because you're mostly working with
herbarium specimens to get like kind of
enough
enough data that's a that's a really
great question and i will say that there
is a lot of color variation within these
species i'm going to come right back to
the play but
really quickly to show you sort of this
is all variation within central pogon
britoniana so it can be
and and you know the other extra like it
can be
pure cream and it can go all the way to
like trying to look like mandonis
but plenty of more characters support
that so there's a lot of variation
within inbridge honeanus which and i
wouldn't be surprised
we did see quite a few hummingbirds and
bats visiting the species
and um and i do think in this
you know in our data it was hummingbirds
bats were both important so i think
that's being a signal here
but flower color was also something we
were hoping to look at a little bit more
in detail
in this um incandesce species as well
um so initially in my postdoc i wanted
to go you know
do what all young optimistic
evolutionary biologists want to do and
go show that there's some patrick
evolution sympatric speciation going on
because when i was a graduate student i
collected these two
individuals in the same um popular well
in the same habitat like basically very
next to each other
and this had wide flowers that were
stinky and white and this had narrow
flowers that were pink
and so um unfortunately when i went back
to bolivia to do field work this had
been taken
over by canna actually hannah bengia and
others under bureaus
um and so it just you know that that
question the ability to ask that
question
specifically disappeared in between 20 i
think 2010 and 2015.
but i think that color evolution and
color being a signal is really important
in this group and in other lobilioids
um including closely related burmeistera
also in iocroma and salinase the
different
colors seem to be playing a signal to
the pollinator so i think it's super
important
and i think that in this clade for
whatever reason the peruvian and
subpleta central pogon
it does seem that it is particular part
particularly labile and very likely
might be one of the reasons why
floral morphology can be pushed in one
direction because of that plasticity
would love to spend more time with this
system
thanks yeah thank you
hi laura thanks for your talk and
showing all those
nice pictures that feel like home to me
and i have a question about the
phenology for example in that case where
you have
all these sympathetic species do they
show like different
time for flowering or something like
that or they are like just
simultaneously flowering
um so
we haven't looked at that with that much
detail i can tell you so i went to the
field twice for this research
and in december and canis isn't flower
and mandonis is in flower and i don't
think for tony anna's
so i do think there's a little bit of
phenology going on but when we went back
in march they were all in flower so
it's not 100 um like you know
it's not this perfect one goes on and
the other comes on and they're sort of
temporally isolated
um there is definitely overlap and we
tried to look at
herbarium specimens to see if there is
good evidence of phases
but there just isn't the bulk of data
you need to really do that but i think
that would be
you know if i had more time in this
system in addition to color i think
looking at a full year's phonology would
be super important as well
and and another like quick one is
did you find that uh like i don't know
for example
how how specific are those those
pollinators for each species do you get
like i don't know ten species of buds
visiting the same the same species and
the same thing for hummingbirds
yeah so um we unfortunately weren't able
to look at the bat
get that species of identification
because i didn't actually collect any
um pollinators unless we didn't have the
permits for that
so but there are two species of bats
that occur in the area
and my post sacrificer who is a bat guy
um thought that it was just one species
but like that's only speculation
but with the two um with
with the hummingbirds uh there's only
one species that visited
uh the low elevation species and then
there are two different
hummingbird species that visited
britonians and mendona so we think
those two species might have been the
entire hummingbird community at these
two because it was pretty high elevation
those are the only two we saw um i
talked to some bird people who
sort of confirmed that it seemed likely
um
generally i don't really think these are
super specialized for any specific
pollinator i don't think
that happens often though i've touched
on two cases in which
there is sort of that co-evolutionary
link that occurs and one would be that
that that video i showed you from
national geographic
with in ecuador so cinderpoke on
agricans with 10 centimeter long flower
which like take out your ruler and look
at that sometimes that's
long that's a long flower so that's like
a convolutionary ratchet that happened
where there is real good specificity and
then the other case of course is in the
center pogon heliconia sickle bell
system where it's
probably a one-to-many relationship
between one bird and
maybe five or six individuals species
and five music species within a
community
that's great thank you yeah thank you
well we're we're out of our time but i
just want to thank laura again for
coming and giving us this
inspirational seminar i think it was
fantastic to see so many
bright pictures as we move into our fall
season and our bright leaves that we're
going to have it's great to see all the
flowers
and um if anybody has any questions as
laura said feel free to email her
or find her on twitter thank you
everybody
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu